but here Ahmed has been a midwife in
umdurman near Khartoum for more than 30
years she's familiar with what her kit
back holds and has used its contents
many times to deliver babies but before
being banned in Sudan she used similar
equipment to carry out what's known as
FGM
I used to carry out the practice on
young girls the last time I did so was
in 2008 on my niece but that hurt me too
much so I stopped the government
outlawed it but people still ask me till
this day to operate on their children
female genital mutilation has long been
part of Sudan's culture those who
practice it believe it protects girls
honor and reputations but medical
studies show that it contributes to
complications during childbirth and
increases chances of infections Sudanese
rights groups have campaigned for years
against the practice and in 2020 Sudan's
then transitional government outlawed it
completely
the practice of female genital
mutilation between the ages of 15 and 49
dropped from 89 to 86 percent in the
decade leading up to the ban and 31 in
girls age 14 or younger the UN
children's agency UNICEF says the ban
has led to a further decline of practice
in young girls to an estimated 25
percent with most of them happening in
rural areas
that's a drop of less than 10 percent
three years on the figure is yet to
reach zero despite those who practice it
risking a three-year prison sentence
mariam's daughters are some of those who
were subjected to the practice even
after the ban was enforced she hides her
face a name out of fear of legal
repercussions
we went to the countryside for holidays
and my mother-in-law insisted myself and
my husband were against it but she's
older and we couldn't say no to her she
promised the Midwife wouldn't cut a lot
from my daughters but the Midwife did
and I didn't find out until three days
later
UNICEF says younger Generations
understand the dangers of FGM and that's
helped lead to a reduction in the
practice but other challenges remain in
ending it all together
The Midwives who continue with the
practice do so because there's no
supervision and the economic situation
the cost of living forces them to
perform it then there's the issue of
awareness of the law we launched a
campaign to raise awareness around the
country that FGM is now against the law
fatia says if she had known the dangers
of FGM when she used to perform the
operations she'd have stopped earlier
she hopes that any awareness campaign
reaches those who continue to call on
her to perform fjm on their daughters so
they don't suffer the consequences Heber
Morgan Al Jazeera Khartoum